Russia invaded Ukraine not only to steal
our land resources and people it's over
that without Ukraine there can be no
Russian Empire
and it is equally although that Russian
bosses are very very afraid of our
democracy yes why because democracy
paves the way for the for the rule of
law get a rid of corruption and to the
key principle of our conference every
person matters it's very important and
of course democracy is in the nature of
ukrainians and we would stress on it
anyway no matter what they think or do
in Russia but we all have to realize
that the more democracy we have the
greater is stressed in our entire region
the more rule of law we have the the
more law will work here on the eastern
time of year and the more transparent
Ukraine is the
ugly any corruption model will look in
Russia
even
Russia's full-scale aggression has not
stopped our internal reforms Ukraine
will be associated with a fair
Fair Court just as it is now associated
with courage step by step yes step by
step we will get there